summoned to war
these armenian reservists are leaving
the capital girovan
president nicole pashanyan called all
men into military service
after fighting erupted on sunday over
the disputed province of
nagorno-karabakh
they will fight their neighbours
azerbaijan for control of the territory
[Applause]
on the front line armenia says it is
bombarding azeri
forces and winning what both sides are
calling a war
the last time they fought a full war was
in the early 1990s after the collapse of
the soviet union
thirty thousand people were killed a
ceasefire was broken in 1994
but sporadic fighting has continued ever
since
nearly three decades later armed with
twitter
cell phone and drone videos information
is a new front line
in the first 24 hours of fighting
armenia and azerbaijan released videos
and boasted of their military
superiority each accused the other of
killing civilians
and of hiring mercenaries from syria and
the wider middle east
to bolster their forces both have also
released videos of soldiers they have
killed
claiming casualties the other denies
russia the eu
and the us are calling for calm while
turkey
is backing azerbaijan
i want to declare that not only
azerbaijan but also
turkey is at war with us they are using
the main modern weapons and ammunition
available in the turkish army drones
and aircraft
hospitals in nagorno-karabakh have
received dozens of wounded soldiers and
civilians
they have moved some patients into bomb
shelters
we have 30 wounded and there are
operations undergoing some patients who
were in hospitals were evacuated into
the bunker
and the seriously ill people are in the
hospital we're working on high alert and
are ready to receive the wounded
azerbaijan said the violence has spread
outside of nagorno-karabakh
with five family members killed in the
city of naftalan
many more were hurt as the casualty
figures climb
armenia and azerbaijan are pushing on
both appear determined to settle
who rules nagorno-karabakh using weapons
and words charlotte ballas al jazeera
we are across this story from three
different locations this hour alexandre
estonovich godfather is in
uh moscow with reaction from there we've
also got cinema kosiolu in baku
azerbaijan
starting with robin forrester walker
though following events
from the georgian capital uh to belissi
take us through
more of what day two has brought
well now we have the armenian defense
ministry
confirming that a total of 59
soldiers have so far been killed
uh and and dozens more wounded
civilians on both sides as charlotte was
referring to more civilian
casualties because the civilian
uh areas the villages and towns that are
dotted along
uh the front lines or the line of
control
are never too far away from the conflict
and those
missiles and munitions that are being
used are not as accurate
as the drone footage that we're seeing
so much of on the military
units appears to show so that is what's
been unfolding
militarily more fighting more soldiers
and more civilians killed in with the
armenians giving those
figures we're not yet hearing about what
the actual casualty
uh rate is looking like from the azeri's
side
um also important to add into this mix
the as armenians now uh asserting that
turkey is involved in this conflict that
turkey has been providing
uh its uh military experts and its
equipment
from f-16 fighter planes to drones but
again
this is an information war and we have
not been able to verify that
independently
and we've also heard again today from
turkey
uh president erdogan saying that he
believes the osce mince group the body
the international body that was tasked
with finding a way
out of this with a peaceful solution
since the 1990s
has failed in its task and that
azerbaijan
rightfully deserves to take back its
territories that belong to azerbaijan
all right robin forrester walker with
that update from georgia in tbilisi
let's move to baku now
uh azerbaijan here is cinema kosovo
yusun and i believe you've been to a
government briefing what are they saying
well yes as soon as we landed in bucky
we went to a government briefing by the
presidential
advisor the former presidential
spokesperson
by the defense ministry so uh basically
the
uh if you look at the number of the
casualties here on the azeri side
the defense ministry claims that 20
civilians have been
injured and six civilians have been
killed but they are not giving
any numbers on the military casualties
on the azerite signs but they are
saying that the armenians who are the
invaders
of the nagano nagorno-karabakh and for
the azerbaijan government
have been attacking the civilian areas
mainly the villages
and there is a fight there is a very
tense fight around tartar city which is
the most populated
uh area in the nagorno-karabakh and the
surrounding villages yesterday we
learned that
the azerites took back seven villages
they recaptured them from the armenian
side
but today uh villagers uh today fighting
is ongoing
10 kilometers to the fuso city which is
very close to
tartar the most populated area we have
been told by our colleagues that
prior to this uh attack from the
armenian side and the military operation
by the azeri's
those villages were in a way evacuated
by the government mostly women have been
evacuated from uh the area because they
were expecting that
attack and we have heard from the
presidential advisory matajian that
uh the houses were attacked
by mortar shells from the armenian side
for instance he gave an example of a
family
where five children with five children
two of them died
ambulances have been attacked also a
carpet school where
uh women in the area go there to learn
how to sow a carpet and sell it to earn
money actually
that building has been attacked so
actually the discourses from
by by both the armenian and the
azerbaijan side are
almost similar come out because they
both accuse each other of
invasion they both accuse each other of
propaganda we asked about the
mercenaries
the foreign mercenaries to presidential
advisor and he said that
azerbaijan doesn't need any mercenaries
their military capacity is enough to
deal with this conflict
in the border but they said that he said
that actually
armenians were bringing mercenaries from
syria and lebanon
to the uh to the contact area as they
say
and where the conflict is ongoing and
since they are not registered under the
military service
the the death number is not being
counted this is what he said
uh also the defense ministry
spokesperson
underlined such an information as well
but
as robin also put through turkey is
involved in this conflict because turkey
has a military base in azerbaijan
and turkey has been involved in this uh
issue between armenia and azerbaijan for
decades come up
and a turkey has been supporting the
azeri military with all the
defense industry equipment it has been
producing as well
but the turkish defense ministry also
issued a statement
making a call that uh armenia who has
invaded invaded
nagorno-karabakh should immediately
leave that area
and stop bringing foreign mercenaries
from the middle east
with that update from baku in azerbaijan
finally
we go to moscow here's alexandre
stonovich
russia with this very important role to
play not so much about taking science
here but about mediating
yes kamal exactly russia is putting
itself
forward as a mediator if there is willed
for a mediation of course saying that
they can use
uh their good relations that they have
with both armenia and azerbaijan to help
resolve this conflict they also warned
third parties from
interfering they called on them to
restrain as well they call uh
the parties involved uh to refrain from
any steps that can
make the situation even more difficult
saying that the situation is sliding
into a war between armenia
and azerbaijan now also france and eu
which are also with russia members of
the osce minsk
group are say are calling for immediate
ceasefire
to going back to the negotiating table
in difference to that turkey of course
is
as we heard uh both from robin and sinan
siding with azerbaijan
and where they are seeing the solution
to this problem is
that armenia should leave the azeri
territories uh
also the disputed area of
nagorno-karabakh
turkish president recep tayyip erdogan
said as robin pointed out
that minsk group actually failed for
decades to resolve this problem so now
it's time for that azerbaijan
to solve it for themselves and in the
line
with uh russian calls for ceasefire and
the calls for
actually the whole international
community for the ceasefire is
also the reaction from the high
representative of eu joseph pharrell who
said
that this should all return to the under
the auspices
of the osce means group so the group
co-chaired with with russia
france and united states alexandre
sternovich
with that report from moscow thank you
for that
right so we're going to put all of this
on the map because it is a region which
i think is
new for a lot of people you hear the
name over and over again the contested
nagorno-karabakh region we've shaded it
in green here
this is the heart of the standoff
between armenia and azerbaijan
nagorno-karabakh itself is
internationally recognized as
part of azerbaijan but the majority
of the populations so we're talking
about these red areas here
they are ethnic armenian and are
controlled by armenian forces
then we add in the shaded areas here the
orange and white areas
also recognize the area recognized as
azerbaijan's territory
but armenia controls it and then you
have
those over there the sort of small
pockets in blue they're controlled by
azerbaijan
now we'll add one more thing in here
which is the so-called line of contact
which separates here it is the green
line separates the armenian forces and
the azerbaijan armed forces
in nagorno-karabakh all this fighting
you've seen
it's taking place all along this green
line
well let's hear from thomas de val now
who is the senior fellow at carnegie
europe
specializes on the caucasus region we
spoke to him and he says that
despite the region's international
importance the outside community remains
disengaged from this dispute
unfortunately this round of fighting
promises to be the worst probably since
since the ceasefire and of course
the war of the 1990s was a very low-tech
affair and now
as we're seeing today a much more heavy
weaponry on both sides so the
destructive power
is much greater but but ultimately this
is a conflict of identity of territory
between
two nations armenia and azerbaijan and
the outside world is not going to solve
it they're going to kind of
try and lead this horse to water but
that they can't make it drink it's a
region of international importance which
has actually grown more internationally
important
um in the last 25 years because of oil
and gas pipelines
through the region it's a region that
borders iran
so sure it's the european neighborhood
as well as the russian neighborhood and
the us
also got involved in the 1990s
unfortunately what what we've
seen last few years is disengagement by
the us in this issue used to
take much more leading role than it does
now um
and cynically one might say that if
azerbaijan has launched a military
offensive
uh in the last as it looks like
yesterday
one of the reasons it may have done so
is because the us is so disengaged
at the moment there's very little russia
can do um apply a bit of
leverage and pressure um but both sides
in a way have to be able to declare
success after a few days and maybe i've
um you know unfortunately maybe if the
casualties mount up and we're already
probably seeing
at least 100 people dying yesterday
and then that may be a reason for both
sides to think that we can't continue
with this